now to washington where president biden
has called vladimir putin a war criminal
for the very first time his comments
come amid a fierce debate over what kind
of aid to send to ukraine following a
speech by ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky to the united states congress
nancy cordes has more from the white
house i think he is a warframe
the white house says president biden was
quote speaking from the heart about
vladimir putin's barbaric actions when
he made that declaration it came after
weeks of the white house carefully
skirting the term war criminal
as the state department investigates
putin's spokesperson called the comment
unacceptable and unforgivable the world
is united in our support for ukraine
earlier in the day mr biden announced an
additional 800 million dollars
worth of military aid going straight
from the u.s to ukraine it includes 9
000 shoulder-mounted javelin missiles
800 stinger anti-aircraft systems and
more than 20 million rounds of
ammunition he's also giving ukraine
seven thousand grenade launchers more
guns and special anti-tank drones known
as switchblades i don't know where the
switchblade drone is but it sounds like
it should be going to the ukraine
but all that still does not fulfill the
top requests from ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky being the leader of
the world means
to be the leader
of peace in an emotional appeal to
congress wednesday zielinski begged the
u.s to help impose a no-fly zone over
his country we're a superpower and
zielinski challenged us to act like it
but a no-fly zone is something neither
the white house nor most of congress
supports for fear it would draw u.s and
nato pilots into the conflict
i have a dream
these words are known to each of you
today i can say i have a need
i need to protect
our sky
as a fullback zelinski urged the u.s to
help him secure more mig-29 fighter jets
president biden should allow those migs
to go to ukraine today
behind the scenes u.s officials are
working to get zielenski something else
he's seeking s-300 russian-made
long-range surface-to-air missiles the
u.s doesn't have them but some eastern
european countries like bulgaria and
slovakia do vice president harris spoke
to the president of slovakia yesterday
and the defense secretary is set to
travel to both countries this week gail
all right nancy let's hope there's a lot
of behind the scenes conversations going
on that we're not aware of thank you so
much